it's 5 20. you know our local economy is  still rebounding from the depths of the  pandemic next week the vegas chamber is  hosting an event to highlight some of  the growth that is taking place and look  at what's next the business expo gives  small businesses a chance to show off  what they can offer  one of the biggest challenges that they  still have is workforce finding hiring  you know retaining a talented workforce  and so this is another thing that  they'll have an opportunity to connect  with people  so the business expo is going to be  thursday june 16th from noon to 5. this  is at the world market center downtown  you can get tickets at vegaschamber.com  or at the door